russell wilson
mr unlimited wow
flying back into seattle been working
out in san diego our drew brees was
there with him at one point what's so
funny there's nothing funny about him
[Music]
he's back no longer limited
participation in otas yeah
pete carroll he's not limited to
commercial flights either apparently
he's just
he's limited to private planes he he
expected
to uh see more of the veterans as they
got closer to mandatory minicamps so
look russell wilson not happy
russell wilson able to compartmentalize
he's not happy
there's a damn thing he can do about it
he's not holding out he's not sitting
out
he's not going to publicly jostle any
more than he already has
for a trade or anything else but as
as he as he walks back in
you know a day after the seahawks didn't
trade for julio jones there's a little
awkwardness there i still believe that
seahawks
had talks with the falcons if they
indeed did just to placate russell
wilson
but uh both aaron rodgers who we
discussed a couple of segments ago and
russell wilson can be saying man they're
taking care of ryan tannehill in
tennessee they went and got
julio jones for him not that russell
wilson is in dire straits with dk
metcalf and tyler lockett but
uh russell back shane waldron the
offensive coordinator they got work to
do
to get ready to try to hold this
together beyond 2021 chris
yeah i mean it's a different situation
to where
it's not it doesn't seem like bitterness
towards russell wilson and the
organization or the coaches towards him
it's a little bit of like yeah we're
just kind of sick of each other
but like let's still go win i'm psycho
pete carroll
i'm gonna chew gum and let's go let's go
and russ like i never
thought for a second he wouldn't be
there at ota you know
first off he just he's the ultimate
professional
and i think he's too into wanting to be
great
and realizing again he's only got the
one super bowl win
and legacy aware and everything like
that to where he's like
i'm not going to compromise my own
legacy and how great i can be
by just not showing up at otas and
things like that so i think he just
looks at this as an opportunity
to make himself better the team better
which ultimately makes him better
look better everything like that and
that's why he's there
hyper awareness of legacy means this is
another opportunity this is another
roll of the dice this is another spin of
the dial
this is another season season number 10
for russell wilson
and i still think there's a very good
chance that this is his last season with
the seattle seahawks
the fans don't want to hear it anymore
they want to focus on this year they'll
worry about next year when next year
comes i'm telling you when next year
comes it very well could be
that that it's russell wilson moving on
whether it's next year or the year after
i do not believe he's going to sign
another contract
with the seattle seahawks i don't think
they're going to want to sign him do a
50 million dollar per year plus contract
which he's going to want
and someone is going to see and believe
that they
can make him into a patrick mahomes type
of a quarterback that team is going to
make the seahawks an offer that they
won't refuse at some point that's what i
predict is going to happen chris yeah
i thought there was a chance what
happened this year there's still a
remote chance it happens this year i
don't think it will
right next year is the hot spot think
about that next year
aaron rodgers and russell wilson
both in play that'll be maybe the sean
watson we don't even know
both of them end up changing teams i
still think there's a chance watson a
better chance
of the three best chance watson still
changes teams this year
yeah it could be it could be that the
seahawks try to run out the clock
another year with russell wilson because
look the more franchise quarterbacks are
available
the less you're gonna get for your guy
yeah i mean you're right about that
but i just can't ima i mean there's
going to be a market for a guy like
russell wilson it's too damn good i mean
it just is i mean even this year with
all
some of the stuff that you had a balance
and really i think the salary and some
of that stuff is really the biggest
issue
we know there was major players in the
conversation for russell wilson
i mean by all accounts we know the bears
they were seriously all in on
these talks and everything like it i
just don't think it made sense for the
seahawks to do it yet this year either
so i'm with you like i i would say
there's no way he's on their football
team in 2022 but
it's not going to affect his work for
2021.
i agree there'll still be a market but
you maximize yeah you don't matter
you're
the only guy you don't maximize it if
you've got desean watson
and aaron rodgers also available
although frankly
of the three all factors considered
russell wilson would be my he might be
the hottest commodity right exactly
right
watson's got you know the off the feel
of things rogers up there in
age and the stigma around him yeah
russell wilson you just gotta
you know deal with danger rust and maybe
you know that
that part of his image consciousness but
other than that
yeah you're right it probably is the
safest one
yeah um i i i look
aaron rodgers may get you a super bowl
or two but russell wilson
if you can if you can manage his
financial expectations
and if he really can be a patrick or
homes type of a figure if you have the
offense run through
him he's going to be with you for
what 12 13 years he says he's going to
play until he's 45 and i don't think
he's a guy who wants to jump around from
team to team
i think he's gonna want a second act
that becomes the final act of his career
yeah i would agree with that too
you know and then you know again it's
it's nice that he says 45 do i know if
that's realistic
i'm not sure if i believe that quite yet
you know we got to get a little further
down the road but either way to like
your point
there's still like the end is is nowhere
near in sight
you know it's still like whoa high level
football play
special player and it's not gonna fall
off here any time
in the recent future that's for sure
there's there's no doubt about that
do like i'll say this do i see a hair
slippage in like his athleticism and
things like that
the last year or two i'll say yes a
little bit
when i watch him on film and things like
that i don't think he's quite as
fast as he used to be no but
i do think he's probably better in the
pocket and making throws that way as
compared to where he used to be too
that's where i'm like
i'm really excited to see what this
offense
you know with shane waldron how it opens
up how it changes
can they make him a little bit more
dangerous i want to see how it all works
there in seattle i'm
rather intrigued by it that's for sure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports